-Welcome, welcome, welcome.
Enjoy yourself.
Have a good time.
Welcome to "The Tonight Show."
You're here. You made it.
Thank you for watching. Yeah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, everyone's talking
about this today.
Just minutes after liftoff,
Elon Musk's unmanned SpaceX
rocket exploded in midair.
Yeah, at first, when people
saw the rocket light up
and start smoking,
they were like,
"Alright, happy 4/20, everybody.
Yeah, we did it.
That's cool. Awesome, man."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Right after the
giant explosion,
Elon was like, "Crap, did we
launch a Tesla by mistake?"
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it took off fast,
was flying high,
and then all of a sudden
it exploded.
Kind of like Ron DeSantis'
presidential campaign.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, but SpaceX hopes
the rocket
will eventually be able
to take people to Mars.
Yeah, and I think I speak
for everyone
when I say uh, you first.
[ Laughter ]
Mars, heaven.
Either way,
you're not coming back. Yeah.
That's right. The rocket
exploded minutes
into its flight, but SpaceX said
that they actually triggered
the explosion,
which is interesting.
But I think how they made
the rocket explode
is even more interesting.
Take a look at this.
There you go. That's it.
Mentos and Diet Coke.
-That's how they did it?
-That's how they do it.
-Wow. How viral.
-Interesting.
That's right.
SpaceX is now saying
they triggered the explosion,
but originally when it happened,
they called it a "rapid
unscheduled disassembly."
[ Laughter ]
That sounds like
what celebrities say
when they're getting divorced.
Our marriage is going through a
rapid, unscheduled disassembly.
Please respect our privacy
at this time.
That's right. SpaceX originally
described the explosion
as a rapid,
unscheduled disassembly.
I don't know. It seems like they
were just trying to save face
instead of admitting
that it blew up.
-I don't think it's that weird.
They're just, you know,
classing it up a little bit.
-What do you mean?
-I mean, like,
instead of saying, "Jimmy,
I need tomorrow off,
I can say something like,
"You know, my body has plans
to be asleep
beyond my predetermined
alarm clock."
[ Laughter ]
-It sounds like you're
dressing up the fact
that you're trying
to get out of work.
-No, no, it's more than that.
Instead of saying, "Jimmy,
I ate your lunch
out of the fridge,"
I'd say "my mouth
acquired a bread
and meat meal
from an unethical source."
[ Laughter ]
-Just say you ate my sandwich.
-Are you mad at me?
-I wouldn't say I'm mad.
I'd say my brain is consumed
with aggravated thoughts
towards my work peers.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, Jimmy, I want to do one.
-Go ahead, James.
-My head smells weird because
I rubbed it against a wet dog.
[ Laughter ]
-What does that mean?
-It means my head smells weird
because I rubbed it
against a wet dog.
[ Laughter ]
-James Poyser, everybody.
There he is right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It's not raining out.
-Hey, get this.
I read about a runner who took
third place in an ultramarathon
and was later disqualified
after admitting
that she used a car.
[ Audience groans ]
The saddest part is
that she used a car
and still came in third.
[ Laughter ]
What?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Third?
She would have come in first,
but she had to keep stopping
for tiny cups of gas.
[ Laughter ]
Officials became suspicious
when she crossed
the finish line and did this.
[ Car alarm chirps ]
[ Laughter ]
Well, finally, guys,
since today is 4/20,
I actually...
[ Cheers and applause ]
I actually wrote a song
to celebrate the holiday.
But then I realized,
you know what?
Kids watch this show,
and I got to set a good example.
So I changed the song
to be about Earth Day instead.
And you could barely notice
the difference in the lyrics.
Let's do this.
Roots, can you give me
a little tune?
What's a good song?
[ Reggae music plays ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
♪ It's a glorious day,
so I'll sing you a song ♪
♪ But first you've got
to sit down ♪
♪ And light up your...
LED light bulbs ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Sit in a circle
and try not to choke ♪
♪ As the room fills up
with a whole bunch of... ♪
Reusable tote bags.
[ Laughter ]
♪ The room's gettin' hot,
kind of feels like a sauna ♪
♪ That's on the account
of dank carbon emissions ♪
[ Laughter ]
♪ Now, if you're feeling buzzed,
I'm not talking mosquitoes ♪
♪ You want to eat a large bag
of cool ranch... ♪
Organic seaweed crisps.
[ Laughter ]
♪ Let me wrap things up,
here's my final point ♪
♪ We should all get together
and light a... ♪
Sign that says "Save the Earth."
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, it's better.
We have a great show!
Give it up for the Roots,
ladies and gentlemen.
Come on now.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh. What a show we have for you
tonight.
-Come on.
-Some of my favorite guests,
my favorite people
are here tonight.
Very, very funny people.
First up, he directed, co-wrote
and stars in
the new film
"Somewhere in Queens,"
getting rave reviews,
in theaters tomorrow.
Ray Romano is here tonight!
-Hey!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The best.
-A delight. Lovely man.
-One of the all-time best.
Speaking of one
of the all-time best,
her new series "Slip" premieres
tomorrow on the Roku Channel.
And you can see her in the new
movie "Beau is Afraid."
Zoe Lister-Jones is joining us!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Big show.
And we got great music
tonight from Flo!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Guys, it is time for "Tonight
Show Hashtags." Here we go.
-♪ Hashtags ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now, since today is 4/20,
I sent out a hashtag,
#StonerThoughts.
And I asked you to respond with
some funny or weird thoughts
that you might have had
when you were high.
Within minutes, it was
a trending topic in the U.S.
I don't know why.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But thank you all
for playing along.
So right now,
I'd like to share
some of my favorite
stoner thoughts from you guys.
Okay, here we go.
This first one is from
@elise millsssss.
-Wow.
-They say...
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Mind blown!
-Or sucked.
-Right.
-Mind blown.
-Or sucked.
-That's correct.
This one's from @--
Oh, I see -- @C0NN3XXX10N.
-Oh, nice.
-C-0-N-N-3-X-X-X-10-N.
-Nice.
-C0NN3XXX10N.
-Yeah.
Ready for this one?
-It's going to bl--
suck my mind.
[ Laughter ]
-They say...
♪♪
-Whoa! Whoa!
Nice!
[ Imitates psychedelic rock ]
Should we do like that?
Like, a little Phish jam
at the end of that?
-Yes.
-Alright, good.
-Yeah, every one.
-This one's from
@LongHairedGuy31.
-Who would think
he'd be a stoner?
[ Laughter ]
-He says...
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
[ Imitates psychedelic rock ]
-Doing, like,
a little bolero there.
-Yeah. A little Ravel in there.
This is from @minnice.
-Minnice.
-He says...
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
-[ Imitates psychedelic rock ]
-[ Imitates water bubbling ]
[ Exhales deeply ]
-This one...
[ Laughter ]
-That was old school.
-This one is from @MrFunkyBeef.
-Dang!
-Ooh!
-Oh! Hit me one time.
♪♪
Hit me two times.
-Mr. Funky Beef!
-Ladies and gentlemen...
-Coming to the stage,
live from his tour...
-[ Imitates psychedelic rock ]
Alright, this one from
MrFunkyBeef.
-Oh, dude,
that's some funky beef.
-He says...
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
Smile, dude.
Ooh, this one's interesting.
This one's from @BluddyHolli.
-Ooh, BluddyHolli.
Like Buddy Holly, but bloody?
-Yeah.
-Damn.
-She says...
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
I don't know why
that's anything, but --
-Yeah, but it's true.
-It's true.
The more I read it -- the more
I read it today, I was like --
-I've never seen a baby pigeon
and I've never seen a microwave.
-This one's from
@RyanBartholomee.
He says...
-Ooh!
[ Psychedelic rock playing ]
-Okay, this is a good last one.
Here we go.
This one's from @Atrvs451.
They say...
There you have it.
Those are our
"Tonight Show Hashtags."
To check out more
of our favorites,
go to
tonightshow.com/hashtags.